the paper is not in great shape and I
also want to say that I I am recording
this so if anybody has any objections I
can like shut it off when we do the Q a
um so we'll see where it ends up as
papers often do it it bloated a bit and
um I had to trim some parts on the hope
that it's relatively coherent but it's
intended to get uh discussion going
although it might appear so the term
public philosophy is not particularly
new in American Academia and broader
culture uses stretch back into the 20th
century for a few examples Walter
lippman's 1955 book of the public
philosophy and Noam chomsky's 1968
article philosophers and public
philosophy figure solidly within one
main sense of the term well represented
by Michael sandel's more recent book
public philosophy essays on morality and
politics like several other fields
activities are emphasis and philosophy
far before the term is coined and
circulated we can look back and see
philosophers engaging in multiple ways
in what we
lost feed
has several decades it has become a much
more commonly used term but one that's
often ambiguous and let's say values
invested and contested so the goal of my
paper is not to try to Define public
philosophy once or once and for all nor
at The Other Extreme is am I going to
suggest that public philosophy should be
a term with meaning so elastic as to
Encompass anything one might like
neither of these is useful for those who
wish to understand what public
philosophy is or could be or ought to be
and how it fits into the broader field
of philosophy or connects with other
disciplines and discourses instead I
will eventually outline a more complex
characterization of public philosophy
that encompasses several main senses of
the term and practice these different
modes of public philosophy who often
intersect and overlap
my proposal is a pluralist one in
several manners I outline a plurality of
different senses and modalities of
public philosophy maintaining that it is
not reducible to one or meaning or mode
and second while I hold that these six
meetings of public philosophy that I
ident identify cover much of the ground
of what those engaged in public
philosophy mean by that term I don't
claim that these Encompass the totality
of what public philosophy is could be
your should be I expect and welcome that
others contribute additional conceptions
of what counts as public philosophy my
aim here is to place a proposal on the
table in order to Foster ongoing
reflection and dialogue so in the time
allotted for my paper hopefully I intend
to do five things the first is to
discuss this recent rise in interest in
public philosophy and why public
philosophy is viewed as important and
timely the second is an examination of
definitions or characterizations of
public philosophy provided by several
organizations and researchers devoted to
it the third is to propose a
deliberately pluralist approach to
public philosophy the fourth proposes an
outline of six main meanings or
modalities or dimensions of public
philosophy and then I want to close by
raising but not resolving some issues
the ongoing need to actually draw some
boundaries and make evaluative judgments
about public philosophy
so the first thing Lee McIntyre one of
The Originators of the ask a philosopher
booth and co-editor of a companion to
public philosophy of recent volume
suggests that when it comes to the term
the notion that and the practice of
public philosophy is what he says it's
more than just the philosophical
profession having a moment over an
enlarged view of what counts as
philosophical and who counts as a
philosophical audience instead in his
view we're seeing what he calls a
full-fledged acknowledgment that public
engagement is now returning to the
rightful place it had at the time that
philosophy was founded and this might be
a little optimistic of an assessment but
several things do seem fairly evident
first in recent years there certainly is
a lot more philosophy being done
discussed and disseminated in public
ways just to make take my own modest
case as an example last night I spoke
about Anselm of Canterbury as part of
the philosophy eats series series at the
Women's Club of Wisconsin and posted an
interview about Anselm's thought I gave
the dogs with torches podcast I
regularly read posts by and sometimes
engage with colleagues on Twitter who
are considerably more engaged with
public philosophy like Helen Cruz Ryan
Van Norton or Donald Robertson if you
spend much time in philosophy connected
circles and sites online you'll see more
public philosophy content than you could
possibly take it
in the past not a few professional
philosophers have events suspicion of
some of the activities falling under the
rubric of public philosophy and perhaps
rightly so worries about a lack or loss
of rigor of debasing Philosophy by
popularizing it these have been long
expressed and perhaps dissuaded some
from engaging various non-philosophical
and even non-academic publics but times
are changing admittedly not always in
ways great for the profession as it's
been traditionally conceived practiced
and reproduced but there are several
factors coming together in the last
several decades that constitute
significant opportunities for public
philosophy in the present one of these
is the general condition of the academic
Humanities increasingly needing to
provide justifications for the ongoing
work and even continued existence of the
profession to those outside of it a
second is a need a desire a demand that
is palpably out there are among at least
some members of the general public for
substantive but accessible engagement
with ideas largely unmet by popular
media and culture and also academic
institutions
a third is the incredible potential
breach the internet penetration of our
world now affords allowing one to find
and reach a public online and relatively
low costs a fourth factor is one
highlighted by CET nagoyan and is
manifestal for public philosophy who
notes if you don't have any training and
you go online looking for philosophy you
can actually understand nine out of 10
things you'll find are from what he
calls the hate web
the number might be off but he
highlights a significant issue if
philosophers aren't providing philosophy
in ways accessible to and of interest to
the public people will get highly
distorted facsimiles of it from others
so we can perhaps agree that without
replacing or supplanting philosophy as
traditionally done taught fostered
published and conceived within academic
institutions there's a role and need for
philosophers engaging in public
philosophy but then we have to ask well
what is public philosophy and another
remark that nagoyant makes sets this
stage well he says I just spent a couple
weeks at a philosophy workshop for
public philosophy and I came out
convinced most of us have an incredibly
narrow view of what public philosophy
could be I think that's quite often the
case so numerous definitions or at least
accounts of public philosophy have been
brought forward over the last two
decades some of these attempt to
encapsulate what public philosophy is
within one formula so we'll look at a
few of these others adopt the approach
of delineating multiple core elements or
Dimensions all of them make some
reference to a public considerably wider
than just philosophy as an audience and
perhaps even include other people as
peers and participants so one of the
commonly referenced definitions in the
growing literature provide is that
provided by Jack Russell Weinstein in
his essay what does philosophy what does
public philosophy do
he says public philosophy denotes the
act of professional philosophers
engaging with non-professionals in a
non-academic setting with the specific
goals of exploring issues
philosophically not bad Michael Burrows
provides a what he calls a stipulative
definition of public philosophy as a
philosophical practice that engages and
or collaborates with stakeholders Beyond
The Academy towards the end of improving
our community so now we see an ethical
goal there uh Lucia
ziglioli offers another public
philosophy is best understood as an
activity that aims to promote rational
thinking in anyone it can reach public
philosophy is a catalyst For Thought
Massimo pigliucci and Leonard finkelman
write that public philosophy refers to a
heterogeneous set of developments that
have taken place over the past several
years broadly characterized by a
conscious attempt on the part of a
professional
philosophers to engage the public at
large now each of these attempts to say
succinctly what public philosophy is and
highlights some important aspect but
doesn't Encompass the totality of what
we call public philosophy so maybe what
we need are characterizations that are a
bit more specific by encompassing
multiple modalities and Sharon mager and
Alan faders to 2010 report problem
practicing public philosophy which was
uh in an APA Committee on Public
philosophy sponsor meeting recommended
the creation of the public philosophy
Network they noted that there were three
main positions that the participants
tended to articulate one was public or
philosophical practice as a public good
and then the second was public
philosophy having the explicit aim of
benefiting public life and then third
was public philosophy as liberatory
assisting and empowering those who are
most vulnerable and suffer Injustice so
this is very ethically oriented Michael
Burrows and Desiree Valentine suggest
public philosophy can take many forms
and they talk about applied ethics and
field philosophy philosophy how Outreach
Service Learning and they propose three
main divisions field philosophy popular
philosophy and activist philosophy
ziglioli's review of the recent
2022 a companion to public philosophy
which calls the volume a collective
attempt to provide a meta-analysis of
what is that issue suggests there's at
least three possible ways to understand
the relationship between the two poles
of public and philosophy these being
number one activity is essentially
performed by professional philosophers
to bring philosophy to non-professionals
the contribution is to that the public
can make to the work of philosophers a
very different notion of public
philosophy there and third the public
and the philosopher working together in
a mutual and reciprocal relation in
order to deal with issues that concern
the community and he construed these are
construed as a form of public education
and antidote to epistemic injustices by
incorporating people who've been left
out and a form of cooperation with and
for the community then we can look at
what organizations people who have the
proverbial skin in the game have to say
so looking at the APA Committee on
Public philosophy the public philosophy
Network and the connected public
philosophy journal and then the
institute for philosophy and public life
and the Society of philosophers in
America if you peruse their stuff you
will find no definitions of public
philosophy lots of characterizations
um and so you know we can look at them
the APA committee declares their belief
that the broader presence of philosophy
and public life is important to our
society and our profession and here's
where the meat comes in aims to find and
create opportunities to demonstrate the
value and social usefulness of
philosophy and then they outline nine
different activities that they want to
engage in most of which actually amount
to
finding media Outlets that will
publicize what what philosophers are
doing so that's not great right the
public philosophy Network aims to
support philosophies as they say as they
engage the public working with
Professionals in government Business
Health Care promoting Community
discussions teaching in schools and
prisons writing for the popular press
and through skill building workshops
organizing scholarly conferences
providing mentoring facilitating Network
building and assisting with projects so
we've got a lot of stuff packed in there
as sort of characteristic activities and
aims for public philosophy they're
Affiliated public philosophy Journal
website quite interestingly suggests
that most attempts at public philosophy
take two forms one is articulating
philosophical ideas in popular terms and
through popular media or orienting
itself towards the Practical by engaging
in a variety of applied studies like
business ethics or environmental
philosophy and the public philosophy
Journal claims that they are fostering a
third modality a collaborative activity
in which philosophers engage
dialogically with activists
professionals scientists policy makers
and affected parties whose work and
lives are bound up with issues of public
concern so that sounds very good as well
right
Sophia the Society of philosophers in
America they have a mission of using the
tools of philosophical inquiry to
improve people's lives and enrich the
professional philosophy through
conversation and Community Building much
greater focus on the collaborative
nature of philosophy and they align
their their work with four core values
public philosophy building uh
philosophical Community engagement
philosophical inclusiveness respectful
communication then professional
excellence and public relevance The
Institute for philosophy and public
life's intention is that they declare is
Bridging the Gap between academic
philosophy and the general public
incredibly vague doesn't tell you an
awful lot but their contribution to
public philosophy involves as they say
cultivating discussions between
professional philosophers and those with
an interest in the subject regardless of
their experience or credentials so you
see a lot of common themes emerging
right and you know it should be evident
there's no agreed upon definition or
even delineation of the main functions
or types of public philosophy but there
are recurring features referenced just
no General consensus on precisely what
counts as public philosophy
so maybe what we need to do then is
recognize that there is a legitimate
plurality two views on what constitutes
public philosophy that articulated by
those who engage in or advocate for it
so a pluralistic approach doesn't
require that we quip let a thousand
flowers bloom and regard anything
someone calls public philosophy is just
equally valuable as any others I'm going
to skip ahead a little bit
um
so I can set out we have five minutes uh
these these uh six main modes that I
would say we could distinguish so
um
this came out of an earlier Sophia
meeting uh here in Milwaukee where we
discussed the nature of public
philosophy distinguishing five main
modes and then I think there's another
sixth mode which is what we're doing
right here right now which is meta
philosophical reflection on what what is
public Philosophy by people who might be
interested in engaging in public
philosophy
so historically the term uh public
philosophy was used in first in the the
first kind of
um sense philosophy intended and carried
out in the public interest right so
littmann's book is a prime example John
Dewey's work you know where he talks
about public philosophy would be doing
that and so you know ancient
philosophers certainly viewed philosophy
as a field extending into the public
sphere
including the political domain and we
have you know contemporary
representatives of this like Peter
Singer Martha Nussbaum Massimo people
yucci or Jurgen habermas philosophers do
engage in uh all sorts of analysis and
arguments and advocacy and they do it in
things ranging from books to op-ed
pieces or interviews and I think this is
what a lot of people think of like the
public philosophy Network tends to think
of philosophy a public philosophy in
this way and then we also do have I
think a legitimate extension of
philosophy into the all these other
fields as applied philosophy so some of
what we do academically could be you
know if we teach a business ethics class
applied philosophy insofar as we're
impacting people are going to carry that
out we might be doing public philosophy
even in the classroom but there's a lot
of Engagement by public philosophers
with other fields an example of this
would be philosophers providing you know
useful Reflections and arguments and
guidance about artificial intelligence
in the present a third distinct modality
of public philosophy involves
philosophers
popularizing philosophical arguments
problems positions and themes making
them more accessible for the general
public hopefully promoting a kind of
literacy about ideas
um
that's also done through a vast variety
of media there's also a fourth modality
of of public philosophy namely
philosophy produced and provided and
engaged in largely by non-philosophers
people who don't have academic
credentials people not trained or
working as academic philosophers may be
interested in philosophy and Carry Out
independent study research and even
produce writing or other media there's
online groups proliferating throughout
the the internet that involves that and
then Sophia actually promotes another
thing which sometimes gets called
philosophy side by side where you've got
the philosophical practitioner then
you've got other stakeholders and
they're working collaboratively with
each other not holding the philosopher
to be the ultimate expert but engaging
in some sort of work together and then
we've got this sixth thing that I
mentioned we're doing here now hopefully
and which other people reflecting on
public philosophy are doing I want to
close by throwing out a problem for
which I have no solution or rather a set
of problems
so
um
those involved in conversation about
public philosophy I think share several
assumptions namely that it's it's
legitimate valuable and needed there's
no consensus definition the term covers
a number of distinguishable modalities
but also that we can make judgments of
better and worse and that some people on
some basis should be better judges of
this and this is where we get to the
sticky stuff right we also probably want
to say that some products and and
projects even if philosophy is invoked
by them they're not public philosophy so
a great example of this all the fake
quotes that you see circulating on the
internet where you've got like
Aristotle's had and something he didn't
say you know then there's entire sites
that are just devoted and churning this
stuff out
I don't think that's public philosophy I
think it's using philosophy even if they
get the quote right I don't think that's
public philosophy now we have to draw
lines and this is where it gets really
tricky right we don't have any consensus
even within the portion of the
profession engaged in it we have to make
judgments of value and we also want to
presumably avoid uh discouraging people
from
being interested in or engaging in
public Philosophy by being too elitist
in our gatekeeping so it's a tough uh
thing to to try to work out and this
certainly has been a problem with the
organizations that are involved with and
fostering public philosophy there's a
lot of gatekeeping that has happened in
the past but the
public philosophy Network which has
gotten somewhat better now or the APA
committee or some of these others
including even Sophia and there's other
related problems that I'll just very
quickly highlight Shane Ralston raises
this this issue of a romantization
romanticization of public philosophy
that whitewashes the dangerous reality
of doing
lose your job and get in trouble
especially now
as legislators
considering the issues of what can be
taught in classrooms Helen de Cruz also
points out that public philosophy risks
or already is an oligopy within pop
culture so I'm just going to end this
here and it's kind of messy but
hopefully there's some ideas in there
that people can grab onto and I don't I
don't actually have all the answers to
these sort of things but I think that it
is important that we you know think
about the breadth of what counts as
public philosophy and how we could have
standards
that are at least permeable to
non-academics or even people who are you
know within Academia
um oftentimes it's people from Elite
institutions with lots of money who
decide what counts as public philosophy
and how can everybody else from
non-elite Institute
Institute so that's all I have I'm happy
to entertain any it doesn't have to be
questions it could just be suggestions
or
we have about five minutes for questions
and then we can put it into practice by
taking it outside yeah I'm happy to talk
with anybody at lunch you know
yeah
Young Americans today about who they
would think of as public philosophers
is tons of philosophy and those kinds of
thinkers but they kind of seem to blend
it with some other ulterior motive to
sell those or to promote a different
butterflies
yeah I mean I I think that um they're
not particularly entertaining Sam Harris
perhaps more so than Peterson or
um anchor
um and a lot of what they do is like bad
philosophy right so in a way it provides
I mean you see this all the time in
Twitter anytime Peterson tweets
something there are professional
philosophers weighing it and they're
like and here's one reason why this guy
is like off base on this which you know
they can provide a nice context for
um engagement you could say but it is it
is a genuine problem that's what uh
goyan was pointing towards is
you know if people who aren't taking
philosophy a bit more seriously aren't
going to do public philosophy then we
see the field too
I mean I I don't think Pinkard thinks of
himself as an Entertainer
but there is like a definite let's let's
think about the lowest common in the
denominator public right so it I I don't
have more than that as a solution to
that other than while we should just
keep running into the breach
ers
have a stronger Baseline for what
modern philosophy looks like yeah and it
can open up like the possibility of uh
oh I better go read this thing over here
I mean a lot we in the the modern stoic
movement the main person that like comes
up with this is Ryan holiday right and
so there's lots of people who will be
like oh yeah red Brian Holliday's book
and he's so great and you know you're
like well some of the stuff on his site
is actually mistranslations and a lot of
this stuff is kind of it it's not like
reading the actual text or the better
researchers who do popular work out
there right now like Massimo piglet
or even Chris guilt who's very academic
work is very accessible
and I always put it when when people are
like yeah but I it's you know nice and
digestible and plus I feel like a sense
of loyalty to him because this is how I
got into it I'm like I mean if you ride
a bike sooner or later you take the
training wheels off right
um why would you just keep going back to
something that's not to go to you know
the issue about why do we study
philosophy because there's something
there that's substantive and you know
robust and that can change our Lives why
would you stick with this kind of second
rate stuff even though it is quite
popular when you can you can be doing
this and you can you can do it with
people who are competent
um understand the material and can
present it in A Accessible way you know
yeah
um well then go ahead
thank you so I think uh thank you for
your uh interesting talk um I think to
the philosophy is to actually to force
once thought to its name is okay
actually this when philosophy is defined
in this way yeah
always eat
um conference the common sense and he
sometimes defies the common sense yeah
but actually
um and and also this kind of like um
activities always requires like once
like um courage and also like yeah and
that only they need like um
like rational faculties but also they
need like consistent effort and
encourage but I wonder actually
um if the messes have that kind of like
courage and the um like the
they can they can put the kind of
consistent effort yeah because like um
for example like in the Republic
when trasma post said like the um
Justice is just like the
subjects yeah it means the justice is
just that that absolute it is it depends
on the um you know it's arbitrary yeah
and when the message heard this kind of
fact
today's really
um like tolerate or because like they
they depends on the common sense and
their common sense that the justice
justice is absolutely yeah so so my
answer to that is there is no such thing
as the masses to begin with there is a
vast variety of different kinds of
people and some might be you know only
interested in common sense uh but I
think when you actually do public
philosophy it's extraordinary to find
the hunger that people have and the
ability that ordinary people
non-philosophers non-academics have for
grasping these sorts of things and even
committing themselves to it one of my
interlocutors who I've been you know
talking to for
about seven years
um you know began as as a kid growing up
in Birmingham was passed through school
had to learn to read in the Army but
eventually got himself to be able to
read uh you know works that he wanted to
including Heidegger's being in time
which is read through like seven times
um if he can do that other people
certainly can
and I think that
um you know the philosophy about pushing
limits and stuff like that sure that's
one definition of philosophy there is no
definition
we have a whole bunch of different types
of philosophy and some may be more
amenable you could say to doing public
philosophy and some some probably less
so and there's topics too I mean it's
going to be hard to get some people
really interested in certain topics and
then there's others that are quite easy
to take
it into but you can go beyond just the
problem
with sense even with those popular times
yeah
okay so well if anybody has any
questions or suggestions I'm happy to to
receive them and I don't want to hold
people back from lunch which is a I'm
looking forward to as well so thanks
very much